normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Target
sells insemination kits now what what
what yes breaking news from me on air
ination they sell it next to like all of
the like sexual care items you know
tampons or whatever else and condoms
since when I know since when I just no
don't know about these things I guess
next to condoms it seems counter product
cuz it's all like the aisles are near
each other I'm not going to talk about
my shopping habits but you know like the
thing is if you're trying to buy any
kind of care item for women they'll put
them next to like whatever it's saying
you don't need men for this this is not
something you need I mean theoretically
it's it could be um an Ode to the
same-sex Community right they're saying
young lesbian couple we have something
you are looking for you to get
itos that on the Target website at home
insemination set yeah and they've got a
they've oh man there's a picture of a
woman holding some uh you know with with
the thing on Target on target I can't I
can't show this image on
YouTube oh don't worry Carter looks it
up he's like oh my God I got to see
this I would uh I would display it on
screen if I was allowed to on YouTube
look I think having children is great
but I think this is a
weird oh my God you was saw it way
Friday show are you serious I'm imp oh
no there oh oh my God there's a photo of
the woman you of like there's a like how
to do you guys have looked at this way
more than I have it's on Target's
website concerning I just saw the box in
the store oh there's a how too good one
of the photos one of the photos shows a
woman's legs on the bed with a hand
coming down with it and it's full and
wow won't be full for long we we that
that video where the the scientist is
walking through the room there all the
babies and the pods we're almost there
they grew that goat or whatever that
lamb in the bag right so we are getting
really close to being able to grow life
in bags no no I'm sorry we can already
do it the question is will the
government allow people to grow humans
in that movie where they grow babies in
in the pods they they passively uh uh
this you you know why the movie was bad
spoiler alerts everybody I'm sorry the
movie was bad because they did not
explore the ramifications of pod it was
just about people who had a baby the
issue is at one point in the movie
they're like um my child was born
through your services he doesn't dream
and they never answer what this is about
and I'm just like perhaps it has no soul
or something like that I don't know but
is that sort of what they're saying
right people who are trying to Outsource
having to carry children are also not
actually that interested in the children
that they create they don't care if they
can't dream they might braise it as a
red flag But ultimately it's about
themselves it's almost like a trophy
that that that's how I mean I feel like
childbearing in general is going
especially when you have like the
same-sex couples just buying kids now it
almost just seems like a trophy at this
point and they're less caring about you
know having a mom and a dad in a
traditional family sorry we have to
ignore that the Middle School it looked
like a CO test of some kind and it was
like all the sudden it's a it's it's
like a jelly you know those things they
used to put the jelly in the jelly
donuts I hate it hear this is gross
jelly donuts forever ruin tget sell hey
hey hey we are we are talking about the
struggles of jenz and how they want to
have families and why their policies are
changing and you mentioned Target
selling at home in salination but isn't
that weird that Target did not bring
this up it's weird to me that Target
would be like well let's just embrace
the fact that we actually don't care if
children have fathers present we're just
trying to see that there this is this
you can have a child and we don't really
care what happens like I just I think
you know your your family planning
business is your own but I think ultim
Ely we would like a culture where it
wasn't just widely accepted that we
expect the family unit to be broken I'm
calling it now at all like these Pride
rallies and stuff you're going to start
seeing Target insemination kits being
given out you're going to see it in a
few years like the next step no but I
mean this this is the other thing like
you know way I think in like 2012 PE
research released a study saying that
the children of same-sex couples
ultimately are not as they don't Thrive
the way children of heterosexual couples
do and this always makes people mad
right because they're like how dare you
question the same seex Community uh but
ultimately you can't live in a universe
where you acknowledge that same-sex
parents are not the same as heterosexual
parents especially when we know father
fatherlessness is one of the main
reasons that children struggle with you
know like women are more likely to
experience te pregnancy if their
father's at home men are more likely to
be incarcerated if they're if their
father's not in the home well the the
violent rates especially too children
tend to be significantly more violent if
they raising a single person household
with just a mother yeah there's no
coincidence I me I mean there was that
first grader who brought his mom's gun
to school and shot his teacher oh yeah
he's he's raised by a single parent it's
not to blame her for anything well a
single mother specifically right yes so
my my question when we were talking
about this on the culture War podcast
was are we not tracking for the uh
detrimental effects on single father
families so I'm I'm wondering if single
father children raised by single fathers
do better than single mothers but but
better and by what metrics so what we
find is is in education and less likely
to commit crime less likely to do drugs
are we checking Mental Health and Social
well-being along with it cuz I I I I
would wonder this based on just like a a
general biased view of women tend to be
more focused on social issues men tend
to be uh women women are subjective men
are objective so when you have a mom and
a dad the dad is the disciplinarian or
he's the tough guy he's the leader but
the mom is the nurturing and the caring
and the social so my question would be
would we be able to tr uh um over large
populations that if a child is raised
only by a father they're less likely to
be emotive artistic creative but more
likely to be disciplined and you know uh
uh not doing drugs and stuff like that I
I don't know I don't know seem like it
would check out but but I'm saying like
we don't actually have studies that
track these things because we are
concerned as Society with are they
committing crimes and going to jail
because we got to pay for that if
someone's like I'm into math and not and
not literature it's like okay well we
don't really care you're allowed so
that's why we say you know single father
uh uh families do better than single
mother but then I think for the holistic
human
experience without in either capacity is
going to be bad for us yeah I think you
need both and that's I think that's
ideal right I traditional family W it
it's just you don't need two of each I
mean I have heard that and I I don't
want to say this with so much confidence
but I had read once that having like
children whose mom stay at home with
their young uh read earlier like i' I've
read that there are benefits to that but
you're right ultimately are they you
know having children as children and do
are they going to jail is sort of
something we're measuring more more
intensely because it has an effect on
the taxpayer hey man this is really
interesting right here nearly half of
white genz women are liberal but that is
the headline I would not use percentage
of white Americans who are liberal the
majority of white gen Z are conservative
the majority of white Millennials are
conservative the majority of white Jed
and Boomers the majority across the
board for white people in this country
they're conservative that's really
interesting so gen Z only 28% of genz
males identify as liberal 46% of genz
women identify as liberal I wonder if
they're saying like liberal within like
the confines of the traditional Liber
liberal and conservative or they're
saying like oh I don't want to call
myself liberal because I consider myself
leftist I wonder if that's part of it I
I don't know how much that would
actually sway the information maybe
you'd have to go into the cross tabs
look at the question
that is a good question oh I love this J
and Millennials were less trusting of
political leaders growing up and still
to this day good work good work
Millennials and jenz equally based on
whether or not we should trust
politicians yeah I saw that it needs to
go lower it needs to go lower for sure
sweet sweet silent three look at yeah
look at them they're like I just believe
everybody they had no access to the
information that we have now this is the
problem with the silent generation
watching their MSNBC they're like but
Joe Biden said it's true so it is like
and he would not lie he is president of
the United States mhm this is really
fascinating video games and uh and
online gaming s in 10 gen Z Men played
video games in the past week I played
video games literally like three hours
ago I played video games right before we
came on this podcast literally 10
seconds but you see that work because
you were playing an ENT an entertaining
show what were you playing it was just
Mario Kart oh Mario Kart I was playing
Baler Skate 3 nice yeah I I've beaten
the game like 47 times already but
there's just so many different stories
and pathways ways you can take look at
this gen Z 71% played video games but
even more women play yeah but they're
playing Candy Crush yeah I mean even if
they're playing Sims 2 they are online
the thing that's true they're they're
doing whatever they are they're avoiding
all social interaction at a high it
looks like look at this graph compared
to the graph of loneliness in gen Z
amongst men too cuz men are now going to
video games for their social outlet
that's my friends jenz listen jenz men
if 71% of genz men are playing video
games and 41% of genz women are playing
video games that means that right now
outside there is a disproportionate
amount of females to M that means it's
it's almost two to one two to one for
every two gen Z women there's one guy
not playing a video game well there's
your opportunity go get them
Tigers they maybe had worked though yeah
with the parttime jobs I think I think
the challenge too is uh if you take a
look back at the other
metric uh these genz men they're like
look you got 72% of genz men are not
liberal and 46% of jenzy women are of
white Americans and so they're probably
meeting women and the women are like are
you into insert insane psychotic woke
thing and they're like no thanks have a
nice day I'm not interested this is
another reason why they're probably like
I am sick of wokeness I am sick of the
left y' everybody's crazy dude that's
why you see the this like this new thing
about passport Bros you know leaving the
country is because of this it's because
they can't stand I know that from
personal experience it's like you
passport bro reality means that you
leave and go to like say camboia or
Thailand or J Japan for instance to go
and find your wife because you can't
find anyone here back in the day we
called them mail ordered brides and you
got them from Eastern Europe true they
still exist I will tell you this right
now though uh gen Z women are gay but
over or they think they are they say
that they definitely the majority claim
to be I at that literally the study says
right here one and three when identifies
as LGBT they wonder why the dating pool
is absolutely it's so weird but hold on
gentlemen gentlemen if women are playing
video games and that means outside it's
nearly two to one for every you know
it's not necessarily that they're it's
they played a video game the past week I
get it I get it but my point is if a
third of jzy women are LGBT that means
for these dudes there should be tons of
ladies out there and you know a great a
great opportunity for you yeah you just
have to go out and do something about it
I mean this is the
this is the issue right so the thing
about baby boomers that that they lived
in a more formal culture right you
didn't have I'm going to text you on an
app and then maybe we'll hook up hook up
a couple times and then we'll leave and
we don't know what we're doing whatever
else there was more procedure in what
you're doing and I think that was an
open conversation in society it's not to
say that the Baby Boomers were perfect
it's just that this was uh this is a
social Norm that we have let go and I
think that makes it harder I think a lot
of young men don't know where to start
and especially espcially you know in the
day and age of me too a lot of men are
afraid to say like well I didn't know
how to approach her so I just didn't
because I didn't want to be a creep I
didn't want to seem weird and so we have
to reinstate Avenues of pursuing women
that exist in a way that everyone was
like yes this is this is a good way to
do it because otherwise you were stuck
between men who want to do something who
feel like they can't because you know
whatever could happen and then men who
do something about it in a really
sketchy Shady way that leavs women there
still a group of people that do no
matter what but they're typically the
the creepier kind you I I got I got to
say just back to the original metric we
pulled up that gen Z supports samesex
marriage less than Millennials and it's
going down people need to understand
what that's going to mean in 10 years in
10 years when genen Z are in their 30s
the the a large portion of economic
power is going to be in the hands of
people who are increasingly uh rejecting
same-sex marriage this could mean within
like a generation or two you get the
overturning of
overfell like it it does not matter or I
should say it matters very little that
you convince someone of your ideas it
matters that young people are growing up
with the ideas and then eventually take
over the economy see a lot of people
seem to think that a lot of what's what
what goes on in politics is we're in a
constant Battle of trying to convince
someone to agree or disagree and there's
people in the middle being like well I
just don't know
now the reality is how many young people
grew up in a grew up in an environment
where they firmly believe based on the
worldview a thing is more or less likely
to be correct and so this is what's
happening for whatever reason gen Z has
rapidly rejected same-sex marriage gen Z
is going to have kids if this trend is
among them what's the trend going to be
amongst Jen Alpha and what comes after
Alpha I don't know thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net